but i'm done rejecting who i used to be
because it is totally part of who i
am i went through you know our big
moment where we we came onto the scene
in 2003 and
fallen and the whole thing um and then i
had this moment afterwards
uh when it it was like so it was
mainstream
like it was in in the big picture um
and then i struggled a little bit with
what that caricature of myself looked
like when i saw it back
um because it doesn't sum you all up you
know and i'm
sure you probably feel some of those
same feelings about the character of you
just as a female race car driver and
that's who you are and that's what you
do and that's all you care about and
that's all you want to talk about and
that's not real
um the truth is we're like multifaceted
people with all kinds of sides and
pieces to ourselves
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
i'm really excited for the guest today
on the pretty intense podcast and that
is
amy lee from the band evanescence we had
such a fun conversation like she's a
really cool girl
very open and is really
honest and has such integrity with her
music
that is what really came through in this
interview for me is just how
rooted in authenticity her every song is
and her every lyric is
and even down to the words so we really
get into how she
makes music and what comes through for
her
to build the foundation for songs and so
you'll understand what i mean when i say
down to the last words
she has a new album out called the
bitter truth and
for those of you who are fans or not she
doesn't come out with albums
all that often so it's a big deal that
she has one out now
and she really took the 2020 energy and
poured that into this album
and spoke some authentic truth
so enjoy this deep dive so you have
who's on your shirt i'm not as much of a
i'm not up on all the right it's
oh there's the police so you got sting
in the boys
um did you have some child like were
there musical
favorites growing up that were an
inspiration or just like
some musicians that you love police are
like
staple outlet music like i'm gonna chill
and not like think deeply about the end
of the world for a moment kind of music
like good
meaningful but in a way that you know
you can relax too
so it's good to have those outlets when
you're a serious artist so you've been
listening to a lot of
the police lately then yeah right
well growing up i listened to you so
much the amount of times that i have
screamed your music from the top of my
lungs
in fact i can't even say it was like
back then
it's still now when your music comes on
like
i still scream it from the top of my
lungs and
your music's the kind of music where i'm
like i feel like i
don't sound too bad and then i turn the
volume down on the radio
and and i go oh i sound terrible oh come
on
harmonizer thank you so much that's
awesome i didn't know that that's great
oh yeah i'm a huge fan like i
i don't does it is it offensive to call
it like
anything other than rock would it be
because i feel like like i also like
alanis morissette and so i i mean i like
kind of like more angry chick music is
what i'd call it is that a thing
no it's wonderful you know it's funny
there there have been plenty of times
it still happens today where i feel like
the odd man out where i don't really
belong because i don't know
like all the depths of like rock and
metal history
i grew up listening to all kinds of
music a lot of my biggest inspirations
weren't rockword artists
um i've been really inspired by a lot of
women and men but
um just people that did things that were
um
outside the box and uh just trying new
things and breaking the rules and being
who they really were
even if it didn't fit into a genre
specifically so
it's funny i'm a rock artist but i've
always
viewed it as a little bit broader
than that for sure so are you a rebel
then
is that how you describe yourself i'm a
rebel yeah i was a rebel for years for
not
the only one in the whole world around
me not to have any tattoos i finally
have one but
um what did you get well it's a
reference to the legend of zelda these
are my live hearts
um i love zelda very much it means a lot
to my family
my brother and i used to play it all the
time so i i got it in honor of him after
he passed away
um and it's it's i just thought to
myself there's never going to be a day
go by that i don't want to think of him
and that time
hmm that's beautiful do you still play
zelda
yeah totally breath of the wild is
awesome they nailed it
they brought it back and they did a
great job it's so good i spent like a
year and a half just trying to get
through it i still have like two shrines
i think it's i think that uh it's really
cool that you would do that kind of a
tribute
it's always nice to have things that
make us feel happy thoughts like there's
so many
things out there that make us don't feel
negative and
you know to be able to like smile
because it's i think i saw a picture at
one point
some maybe it's on your social is it
hearts right yeah it's like you know
your energy
it's actually the tattoo that he wanted
to get and then he didn't get a chance
to get it
so after he passed away i was like okay
i'm gonna get that tattoo
but um being a rebel
means something different i think uh
depending on
the circles you swim in you know um
and for me it was always a cool thing to
stand out
it was a cool thing to be a woman you
know in a world
of of rock guys it was a cool thing um
to to embrace femininity um
when masculinity was key and it's a cool
thing
not to have tattoos you know because
everybody did
but if if i was in a different place i
think it would
have been a different thing it just
depends on who you are
first of all just being true to yourself
but um i don't know
what made you feel comfortable to
be different i've been inspired by
a lot of people i mean as far as being a
musician
um i was i did talk about that again um
like in high school it was the
alternative grunge like
the more unique the better era and
that super inspired me um bjork
is probably my all-time favorite artist
um
and it's just that there are no
rules it's it's just so pure and and
truly real and authentic
and authenticity is what draws me to
artists the most
um just feeling like wow like they are
they are real and they are who they are
and that's beautiful
um so i don't know i think i i've been
inspired by people that that broke the
mold um you're definitely one of those
people that has
you know broken the mold not to not to
do the thing on you that you probably
always have to talk about
but um i have to talk about it all the
time so so should you yeah
you know breaking through and and
following following your dream
you know and and doing what you love
even though it's
it it doesn't add up to everybody and
it's not what they expect to see
that's kind of even more exciting yeah
you know i always loved being different
i had no
i'm like i always felt really honored
and like
lucky to stand out um
and then so yeah i totally relate to
that but one thing you said
was about you you resonate with
authenticity and it
made me think of it makes me think of
music and it makes me think of
um what allows you to be able to feel
that authenticity and so i'm wondering
if from a
musical tone energy perspective
do you think that authenticity and truth
do you think there's some kind of
frequency to it or energy or how do you
like the basically how do you know when
someone's being authentic how can you
actually tell
oh um i wow like a lie detector
like how can you tell if somebody's like
a poser or not i don't know
right like you can feel it you feel it
because
i don't know that's hard that's harder
to define um
you just see yourself in people you know
you see things that you're like i relate
to that thing you're saying and that's
hard to articulate
um music is cool because it's a place
where we
can express things that uh
go beyond just like language you know
it's a
feeling it's it's a moment it's a memory
it's it's just part of your core and
part of the thing that binds us all
and when you see somebody expressing
that in their own unique way
i don't know you just i'm drawn to that
yeah that makes sense because we don't
when we see things we don't
see them as they are we see them as we
are yeah
right that's a really complicated
concept that takes a long time i know
i i know i know i'm sorry you're making
this no it's totally
no that's you're in my you're in my
creation zone things get weird things
get deep really really fast
that's like where i live i mean i live
in that sort of
like that mode of frequency and energy
and spirit
and consciousness and all that stuff are
you into i mean i don't
the fact that you understood what that
that those words meant
means that you have dove into that
aspect of
existence or well that's my job
like to like consider the gravity of
life
and what we're doing here that's always
been like this thing for me
like to use music to try to discover
the secrets of the universe um and
connect with other people through it you
know
something really really incredible that
i couldn't have expected
um when i was just making music as a kid
in in my room in high school uh
was what it would be like to stand on
stage
uh in a room with thousands of people
and
everybody experience the same
indescribable thing you know at the same
time
through the power of of music and and
art
and when everything comes together and
i don't know it's hard to explain it's
transcendence and
when you feel that thing where there's
there is
obviously a higher plane like there's
more to life than just
buying groceries and going to bed and
waking up again my body
my body's giving me goosebumps saying
yes there is like
yes and that's fascinating to me and i
don't know the answers
and searching for those answers and
those connections
really for me was born out of grief i
lost my sister when i was little
um and my family's been through a lot
um and just like wanting to connect and
and and and wondering like what could be
possible
you know what what is what is real and
and what is time and all these like deep
concepts
yes how our spiritual energy could still
be together and
i don't know i'm having a full circle
moment with this album and this process
and this time
there has been so much loss in the world
and i'm feeling
like not in a negative debbie downer way
like
connected to humans that i don't know
through music and wanting to pour that
thing out and
and just spread hope like i really do
have hope for whatever it is i really
have hope for a better tomorrow than
yesterday 2020 was so hard
but we all had to like really face
reality
and and a lot of us like looked in
um and i did i mean it wasn't always
easy but i spent a lot of time in this
room
just going deep on myself and
um processing uh my life from now
you know to then to the future and
and how we are all connected and how it
all
is one circular thing i don't know it's
hard to explain that's why i write
lyrics instead of you're making
perfect sense i just got done
interviewing theresa caputo who's the
long island medium
and she wrote a book called good grief
and so she was talking about just that
very same concept of how
grief can be good and it's in that sort
of
ability to grieve that you to
in order to grieve you are sort of like
alchemizing
for you to be able to have a perspective
of grief of being like a positive thing
i think is an evolved perspective
so what did you like i'm really
curious about making what it was
like and where you were at oh i like it
i'm wine i love wine first tip of the
interview here we go
i make wine you just have to let me know
where to send some
okay i will tell you right after this
interview that's amazing perfect
um making music and the sort of
space that you were in um
in your maturity and your awareness
level
before you made but you know before
early 2000 before you made
fallen album to let's say
the space that you're in now making the
bitter truth album
like what can you even i mean like put
them side by side
put amy side by side describe her
i'm still me that's the coolest thing
and i've made a really really long
journey to get here
um i've experienced so much more and i
feel
different in my perception because i
know more um but also i'm aware that
maybe i knew less all along i feel like
that's the hugest lesson is that we are
just totally i look back on some of the
stuff that i used to say i've been going
through all this old footage
of um the first like video camera i ever
bought when we first went on tour
and it's been in all these little micro
tapes um in this thing right here
since like 2007 was the last time like i
even looked at it
and i'm just like oh my god you're such
a dope you think you're cool
what was in it it's dumb i honestly
mostly i was thinking oh i'm going to
capture the show but
had like the audio all the way up so
it's just like
like completely unusable um footage of
our concerts from back then but
no there's a lot of like just backstage
hanging out walking through the dressing
room trying to just document my life
because it was really cool and it was
really new and wild you know i just
wanted to remember it i'm really glad i
did it
um but at the same time i hear myself
talking and you know you're just like
you're such a dumb kid
no i know even now yeah i don't listen
to anything i don't have to listen to
or feel like i need to listen to to get
a little information
i don't like to do that um so but the
answer is i've grown a lot
but i'm done rejecting who i used to be
because it is totally part of who i am
i went through you know our big moment
where we we came onto the scene in 2003
and
fallen and the whole thing um and then i
had this moment afterwards
uh when it it was like so it was
mainstream
like it was in in the big picture um
and then i struggled a little bit with
what that caricature of myself looked
like when i saw it back
um because it doesn't sum you all up you
know and i'm sure
you probably feel some of those same
feelings about the character of you just
as a female race car driver and that's
who you are and that's what you do and
that's all you care about and that's all
you want to talk about and that's not
real
um the truth is we're like multifaceted
people with all kinds of
sides and pieces to ourselves so i had
this like really i don't know what the
word is
disenfranchised disconnected sort of
dissolution moment where i was like
maybe i want to quit
maybe this isn't who i ever was maybe
it's just a role something i was doing
in high school
you know that was cool and really like
that's not the whole pie
and i i've had i have always taken my
time in between albums to just like
decide what i want and what i really
want to say and what i really want to
express and what i really want to do
with my time
and i always come back to it
because it's real um and it doesn't mean
that i put on
eyeliner wear courses every day because
i don't that's silly that's character
but really when i really go in deep and
and do the thing that feeds my soul it's
pouring out music that sounds like
evanescence
so that's amazing to be here in this
moment
and having last year be this kind of
lockdown at home
time to focus on it and go you know what
i'm going to totally do this and hear
what it sounds like when it comes out
and it is different it is new and is the
future but
at the same time the core of who i am is
who i was
and that makes me feel awesome because i
i don't have to like
reject something that's that's that's
here it's here and it meant that then
too um that doesn't mean we can't grow
and
learn things and be better people you
know and i i
am i hope that i am but uh at the same
time you know like
i'm proud i really am like i'm i'm proud
of everything that we've done
despite all the obstacles and and all
the searching and everything
it's good what were those things that i
mean
[ __ ] like kudos because that's a journey
and that's
hard like the work is hard yeah like and
i don't mean like
the driving the race car the singing the
songs like
the work on the self is hard
so what did you deny then that you now
embrace
and say i'm not gonna hide this aspect
of me or i'm not gonna deny it i'm not
gonna
cover it up i'm not gonna be embarrassed
or shameful or any of those words that
we don't wanna have to be
i think it's about being the sad girl
you know one of our biggest songs was my
immortal
and um it's a beautiful song um
and it is kind of out of grief and you
know singing about
just just a tender ballad it's
dramatic and emotional and just like
vulnerable
you know and um it's funny and cool
actually because like we're not
vulnerable isn't the word you would use
if you were thinking i think to distract
describe my band
it's a hard rock band um but we have
that contrast and that that drama
um and seeing the character of it again
i
i like using that word now all of a
sudden because it that's what it's like
it's like you express and then you see
the reflection reflected back to you
from people's perception of that and
you're like what
that's not exactly what i meant like
that's kind of like a cartoon version of
of the real thing
um but what i the problem with the
character is that it looks like
mellow drama oh i'm always dying
everything's horrible and hard and
dramatic and like the end of the world
and life and death and
save me from the nothing i've become you
know and i
that's real but it's not the
if we're sitting here talking together
today like that's that's not the person
that i am
in a nutshell and i think the thing that
i wanted to run from
for a while was that drama i don't want
drama
i put that stuff into my music so i can
let it go
and be the funny one and be healthy and
you know like
have a good time and go make music and
and have a family and all that other
stuff
wow that's so fascinating so music was
like
i mean yes music is your outlet but and
the word that comes to mind is almost
like your
dump it's almost like you're like you
throw it into the music
and get it it's like it's like your
alchemization process
yeah instead of free um and
that's why like some of the darkest
things are
in our music and some of the biggest
struggle all the biggest struggles of my
life
are in there and there was a lot to say
this time and a lot to get off my chest
especially after 10 years
since we put out a full album um so much
has happened since then good and bad but
just big
um so i put out the most
um the biggest outpouring i can that's
music
uh so that yeah so that then i'm giving
an interview and they want to talk about
it i'm like i don't know
i just i like ice cream
do you feel like it's i mean i want to
talk more about vulnerabilities i'm
curious if vulnerability
has always been easy for you um but
do you feel you just said something that
made me think
is is there an aspect to music or making
it that
that sort of feels more like a
channeling like it's not you
yeah um it is me but
there's something when when i start to
write a song
um when i start to write lyrics
like i don't think about the lyrics
first it's just like mood and and
sounds um and the first things that come
out of my mouth
i don't want to let like thinking about
what the words are going to be or what
the songs
about slow me down so it's just
subconscious it's just stream of
conscious it's just blah blah it's not
even like
english um but some of it is
like words come out like it's just from
this kind of subconscious place of
feeling
um and then after like the basic core
is kind of there then i start to sort
through what i have
and when i build what i'm gonna sing
there's a part of it that's always like
kind of just sifting through what came
out without thinking and going what was
i what was i feeling
without thinking about it and almost
always
a few words come out of that
subconscious place
and i feel like there's something other
that is
like just coming through i i feel like
it's my subconscious
i'm a big dreamer i dream really really
really
vividly um cool i like you
um like i'm not like i literally like
play out situations i resolve problems
like
um same yeah all kinds of crazy dreams
so i
it's kind of like from that place like
something comes out that i that i know
is real because i wasn't trying to
to put on a show i wasn't trying to tell
a story or portray a
a good looking side of myself is just
what really came out and then
there's also something else that has
just become
sacred to me about um the lyrics
that it that i can't lie um
because it's for me like i can and i
always have this safety in the back of
my mind that like i don't have to tell
people what this is about
i can always do an interview and just
say something vague
and not go into it but like i have to be
true to myself
and say the thing say the thing that i
have to get off my chest that i don't
really want maybe you want anybody to
know or that i don't want to talk about
it's just that place where i can't lie
um and because
it's that thing for me that's part of
why it's so cathartic and healthy
oh my god you what i'm feeling is that
by you since we're only seeing ourself
in things
that by you sort of channeling this
energy and getting it out you
you are literally giving people an
opportunity to take their same pain or
same feelings or
or even if it's not the same but not the
same thing but it's a feeling that's
similar
this music is their outlet as well i've
seen that it's so beautiful it's such a
gift
it's it's something that's pushed me
forward on days when i didn't want to do
it
when we're on tour and we have a meet
and greet and people talk about their
own
totally unique experience of
struggle and like a hard time in their
life or um you know
living with a a a family member with a
disability or losing someone or just
like a crazy divorce just
stuff people have been through and their
specific words are like this
means so much to me you know like this
is what helped me through that time
um and that is the biggest gift because
it's doing something that i can't
control
um it's just it's just an awesome
awesome gift
through just the connection through
honesty and art
yeah it's like you i'm gonna get super
it's like almost like you
open up a channel or a portal or a or a
energetic sort of like shaft to like
allow this energy to flow that's that's
i can't wait for you to hear this record
there's totally a song i've already
i let me guess what it is because i've
listened to i've left i've listened to
the songs let me
um hmm
well the one that probably resonated the
most was wasted on you
oh cool i like that song it kind of felt
like a breakup song i don't know if
that's right or not totally
and then it became like perfect i want
to break up with this moment when cobot
hit
and we were all stuck i was like this is
totally our first song
because you know it's it's about that
but i like broken pieces i thought that
like had a really good sound like i love
the
guitar in it thank you yeah um that
sounded super cool and then game is over
it's just like i mean that's just you
like shining there's a song called um
part of me that uh it's not like a
single or anything it's later in the
record it's one of my favorites
um i listen to it a lot for motivation
it's it's about
like a common theme on the album but
um like rising up
from the bottom um and just
standing up to face it and and that
thing that you're talking about i kept
wanting when it gets to the chorus like
i'm pouring out my love
for music my relationship with the music
what we were just talking about honestly
um i mean it doesn't have to mean that
to everybody everybody doesn't have the
same experience that i do but
um drown me in your blinding light i'm
just like visualizing
that feeling like standing on stage and
whatever that is
um it's like
like the hole that opens you know
um from our pain can also be a way in
yeah um like let that light like pour in
and
and be a a channel like an an open
thing you know and and let it be
something good you know if we can take
these these trials that we're all going
to go through in our life everybody's
going to have
something something eventually at least
at the end you know where they're gonna
have to face
our mortality and and everything about
this life that is
fragile um and experience those losses
like if we can take that
that pain whatever your struggle is and
turn it into something good
and something that shines light and let
that vessel go two ways let that hole
also be you know like a way out and a
way in then
then our time isn't wasted you know then
we're we're giving back
because also the world is a beautiful
place you know
um and and worth worth living for and
worth fighting for
for sure you're doing that like i don't
even
i don't know you obviously and we're
just talking for the first time but
the energy of your of you and your music
like i'm i'm able to obviously
mirror back what you're doing i know i
love it i can totally relate to you we
should talk after this
yeah we should is vulnerability always
been easy
or i mean like no it's hard okay it's
hard that's why i love it
it's it's hard but it feels good um i
part of you know talk about that because
vulnerability's hard for people so
it's hard and then feels good and like
give me the arc of that so
it's still it's still a struggle you
know and it's not
obviously it's not something you can
totally control um
being in uh like the hard rock
realm vulnerability is not generally
embraced
it it's not that it doesn't exist it
does um and it's my favorite part
um but it's not normal it's not like
that
when you have your you know idea of
you know what hard rock music is it's
about like yeah
you know fight the power being strong um
it's not about showing the times when
you've
felt like maybe you're wrong about
something or that you're weak
in some way uh that's kind of the
opposite but to me
that's why it's so striking um because
it's so real
and for me what's always inspired me
like we're talking about before is
authenticity
and if i'm going to be honest and i'm
going to be authentic
then i have to admit that um i'm not
perfect
and i'm not always feeling strong um and
in
in our performances
i'm able to let that out and let the
broken pieces shine
let it be beautiful make those flaws a
feature
um and and let myself feel that way
that's the challenge
is the things that even like when you
finish a recording and like choose the
takes you're going to use i've gotten
more and more and more to the place from
from our first
time doing it where i gravitate
towards the things that are just human
and didn't come out on purpose that i
wasn't trying to do
kind of a perfectionist so i'm always
trying to get things like super super
perfect but then like my voice will
crack
i'm like oh we got to use the one where
my voice messed up like that's the
coolest part
that's where you can hear who i really
am you know and it's brave because it's
not what i wanted and it's not what i
can control but that's what's beautiful
but perfection can be looked at
different again it's your it's your
perception of perfection so
like if being vulnerable is the hardest
thing
and you just kind of like let it out and
you felt it in that moment and that
right that that one that that time you
sang it but your voice crack
you actually were perfectly aligned with
your intention of the music it's like
hearing somebody's heart and a lot of my
favorite singers it's not that they're
like the most perfect
like singer that would do a good job on
broadway it's that
they're that i hear that their soul
through their voice
it's like you that's what we love right
when we hear somebody we can really
relate to and go oh i believe them i
believe what they're saying right now
so i don't know really
how what is the window of opportunity
for artists to really do what you're
doing to
to be in the place that you are that you
are able to do that because it feels
from the outside looking in like there's
so much
control and there's so many you know
with record labels and
deadlines and whatever like do you have
to like do you have to be like i don't
know another artist that comes to mind
that feels like
you know they came onto the scene so big
in the beginning that they earned the
ability to be able to be authentic be
like pink or something like that you
know where like
you get so big so quick just like you
did and you know then all of a sudden
you're able to
sort of sort of live under your own um
set of rules yeah and use your own
original money from the first time to
pay for the next thing because it's
never going to be as much to do
beforehand
um yeah totally and i consider that a
gift
like i see that as i there's no recipe
for that
we really got lucky like there is an
element that
there are so many artists out there that
are great and unrecognized
it's not just that the best ones make it
and the other ones fall away no
it's it's more than that like things had
to kind of happen at the right time
and it is a gift um i have to say that
just because of all the wonderful
friends that i know that haven't had the
success that we've had
but something that i've always fought
for
and it could have gone different after
that first album
is that authenticity and not to sell out
and
oh that worked do the same exact thing
again be exactly who you were
and just you know what actually let us
find some writers for you
and and just we're going to get you
another single
that's not real that's not what i signed
up for and that's not
i don't believe why people gravitated
towards us in the first place
why we earned our fans that we had the
incredible
luck and opportunity for them to hear us
in the first place that's huge i can't
control that
but the fact that like it meant
something deep and touched them
that's the thing that's the spark that i
have to maintain and hold on to and that
i have and will always fight for is
to be my real self as much as possible
and i think that's why
um as the years have gone by more and
more
um i'm pushing myself in that direction
um rather than more and more like how
can i
dominate the airwaves it's more how can
i more and more embrace
that authenticity even if it sounds a
little bit different now than it did
when people first heard bring me to life
you know um
and i don't know it also feels good to
me because if it totally flops and
everybody hates it
i still love it and i'm the one who has
to live with it forever well look that's
the thing
that's a beautiful place to be and not a
lot of people are brave enough to do
that
you know not a lot of people i think are
brave enough to
i'm gonna bet that you don't probably
live with a lot of regrets then
because if you're your authentic self
and
you are proud and happy and in alignment
with what you did and you'd use the best
of intentions
and put everything that you could into
it then like regret would imply
that you wish you'd have done something
different i don't have regret when i
listen to our music
i always feel pride when i listen to our
music i really do
um and a lot of memories a lot of good
like
i remember the time whether it's
performances or that time
writing it or even at this point other
people's stories
um have entered into it to where it just
feels like it's something bigger than
myself
um that makes me feel awesome and yeah
no regrets
no regrets on the music what um what was
your most sort of
surreal moment that you look back and
you are able to
ruminate on and just like takes you back
emotionally
we got to um there have been quite a few
really cool things
um shoot i'm stuck between two
tell them both well we got to
we got to play the sydney opera house we
sold out the sydney opera house two
nights in a row which is wild because
it's not a rock thing
um we were just we we toured with um a
full orchestra for our synthesis
project in uh 2017 2018 and i was really
really special and
really emotional um and it was a crazy
emotional time for me because it was
when i was just
first when my family was grieving my
brother just a month before
um and we couldn't cancel the show and
it was like the first show back and
i'm on a plane to australia just like i
can't sing
um but i have to go like i know that i i
want to go
like i know he would want me to go like
i've got to do this
and just the feeling of like
that was one of the most like
transcendent feeling emotionally like
performances ever
i felt like everybody in the room well
we were all just souls
i couldn't even like see it normally it
was just lights
it was just like something
i knew i was where i was supposed to be
those feelings are
amazing um another time um
years before in i think 2011 we got to
play
um the nobel peace prize concert
with a bunch of different artists i feel
like we were the only
rock act they just had all these
different genres supporting
um and all really cool ones just
different
across the board unique neat artists
and we played for like kings and queens
and
just just amazing amazing people who had
changed
the world and that was the year that um
all three
of the nobel peace prize winners were
women and
they were fighting for social justice um
and it was just this
amazing thing you know like to be like
do we really
belong here because i i have had
so many of our greatest moments i'm like
we snuck in here like we're the kids
that totally crashed the party and snuck
it back we won those grammys
i did not expect to win the grammys i
had my shoes off um i
literally the whole thing had just
happened kind of in such a jarring way
that i'm like nobody
really knows who we are like that
right like i'm being pumped like this is
like the scene in carry and they're
about to just
dump a bunch of pigs blood on us and
laugh like so
from that to like you know just kind of
recognizing like okay
like this is real it's not just for us
it's it's something
bigger than that that's the best that's
that's the greatest
the greatest feeling and i definitely
felt that when we
we got to play that nobel peace prize
thing it was like do we belong here just
like
this is this is so an honor
it makes me think of the word surrender
like when you can
sort of set an intention for something
that you want to accomplish or do
um and then you surrender to the outcome
right
you free up the energy to let it be
something that you couldn't even imagine
right right totally yeah because
because life does have the ability to be
greater than we can imagine
yeah just have to like let go of control
a little bit sometimes
yeah do you um i don't know like i
do you have a spiritual practice or like
just your awareness level for all this
makes me think that there's some level
of either like
interest you have or books you read or
podcasts or youtube or
i have a lot of deep conversations with
friends um for sure
i've always been a spiritual person i
think my mind
you know kind of went to that place of
of thinking about like
the afterlife and and what are we here
for and what happens after we die
when i was six and my my sister passed
away
um it just it it just put me on a path
to open my mind to oh that can happen
well what does that mean
like how how does that work then like
what what am i
like and what what is the value of our
existence
i mean i was raised as a christian um
and i still am um but
it takes like a really truly open mind
i think um to see it
in a way that is really broad and
and accepting the part that's like this
is more than you can understand
um and i think that that is key
there's a lot of a lot of great beatles
music um
that really inspires me and makes me
feel like
that gets me john lennon gets me it's
something
it's something more it's just something
something
untouchable and and beautiful and
personal at the same time i
i don't have the answer but um i
think that the search is totally
important and a big part of why we're
here
is to be asking those questions you and
your friends haven't come up with some
sort of like
cult no no
[Laughter]
pretty all-inclusive yeah i like
listening to people
i like listening to other people's
interpretations and ideas and
and and thoughts about about the
universe um
because i think that the more we listen
and the more open we are
like there can only be gain from that
like we should use each other and listen
to each other and
i don't know one left yeah i agree
so how do you know when you're ready to
write another album you know given that
you spaced them out and you
get into you know you you obviously feel
your way into the next album
what happens or what do you feel when
you're finally like okay
it's time yeah
it's only happened a handful of times
hasn't it
um it's hard to explain i
i'm something that i love about um our
time now is
it doesn't feel like it has to be so
structured um
over the last decade it just hasn't felt
like okay if we're going to make music
it has to be
this many songs we have to do it all
once we have to go in and
have an album um it's just freer than
that
and i definitely wanted um to just
express myself in different ways and
kind of just
learn have some educational experience
as a musician as an artist as a person
to just kind of go down some different
roads and see who i am
um so some of that had to do with
evanescence and some didn't
um when our band got signed um
i was had just started going to college
and um my other thought um
was like for my day job was i wanted to
study
um theory composition and become a score
composer
and a lot of my heroes in music are
score composers people that
write music for film um and
that's the hard part i have a good ear
and i can cheat and i took classical
piano for nine years
um but i could cheat if i could hear the
song
i could play it not exactly instantly is
i'm not a genius
nothing like that it takes work but that
made me know that
what i need is the discipline to like
sight read and understand music and be
able to really go if i'm going to do
that if i want to be
somebody that's really writing music for
a living and and
being like my heroes i want to
understand music
for real and there's work to do um so
i got a chance you know after
um in the last 10 years to to spend some
time
actually scoring independent films um
with friends
um and i made a kids i have
a child i have a six-year-old son named
jack he's awesome it's the coolest thing
i've ever done
um yes it is my greatest accomplishment
by far i mean hands down i'm 38 and i'm
like is it highly recommended
yes yes do it
do it it's incredible it blew my mind
especially if you're into like
spirituality and
opening your mind and stuff nothing in
my life has opened my mind like that
it's all connected it's crazy it's like
getting a glimpse
into like the big picture
it's wild it's amazing and he's
my best friend i love him so much um
but that inspired me you know to make a
kid's record with my family
um so my dad and my uncle and my
siblings and me and even jack
you know for a second made the music
that is
like the best version of us you know
sitting around
guitar pool style at christmas um and i
never would have done that
i don't think if it wasn't that i was
thinking like
through his eyes and like being a kid
again and like
thinking about the songs that my dad
sang to me and then like writing new
ones like just to just like get through
the moment when we're changing a diaper
or whatever
um so
yeah i know but exactly um
so i don't know going down those other
roads was good for me
um and rounded me out a little bit and
also
it just makes me feel even more like for
sure
in this moment that we wanted to make
this album um
when the path after going a long way
around like
leads me back here i know it's real um
and
it is a really special beautiful thing
to get to play in a band
just that simple it's fun it feels good
it's powerful
it's really it feels good um and
after becoming a mom there was
definitely a part of me that was like
i don't know if that i can do that
anymore i don't know if that's still me
i feel like i'm 200 pounds you know
forever and
then i signed up to do a show we got
some cool offer to play some big
festival in japan
and i remember like being like okay i
hope i can do this
and as soon as i stepped on stage
totally
of course that's who you always were and
that beautiful realization
was just ah such a beautiful thing
for me it's so good for me um
2015. so we kind of delved back into
playing shows a little bit starting then
and then went into the creativity of
messing with our old music with the
let's re-record restructure redo
um our favorite old songs that are like
kind of classically minded from that
classical place you know
that thing that i love and the
electronica and just like
strip back the band and make it this
other side of our music and push it
forward
that was cool and fun and scratching the
itch that i had
and then it's like once those itches are
all scratched it's like well now i want
to rock
come on let's do this so there's all
this pent-up aggression and we're all
like raring to go
um and yeah we we just started we
started writing songs for this record in
2019
um like bubbled up it just basically
bubbled up yeah
like and then the world went crazy and
there was even more like of that
pent up like there's no time to lose we
don't know if we have tomorrow
you know energy fire happening so the
album
is is is full of a lot of
fight like a lot of like i'm not going
to lay down and
be done like we have more to say because
we did
so what then what's your and maybe
they're the same but
what is your favorite song that is the
most meaningful to you from the album
which i know it's always hard but i'm
going to ask you anyway
and then what do you think which song do
you feel like
captures that point in time that point
in history that we were at in 2020
when the world changed it's really hard
to pick a favorite
i i know that's typical but i've
i've been asked that question in quite a
few interviews
and i feel like every time it's a
different answer um
because it depends on the mood that i'm
in and what i wanted to do with the
album was
um show all the sides you know
let there be the separation there's no
one song
that sums me up you know
that makes sense because we as people
hold all aspects of potentiality so
how can you possibly say one represents
the total
when you're asking for a fraction yeah
my favorite
uh like this week
might be better without you i i really
love that song
it kind of was it was written sort of at
the last minute as a band
which is also a challenge that's not
really my like safe zone
like i like to write by myself in a safe
place and then bring my idea to the
group and then we
do it together from there but to really
like in the moment come up with the
ideas together
um on the spot like that that's that's a
more
high energy go go go go go like somebody
come up with something good or we're
moving on
kind of thing uh and it was one of those
songs i love that
um i love my band i have a really
talented group of musicians around me
that
uh we all push each other we all have a
little bit of a different style
actually so when we come together it
makes something different than when i'm
working by myself and i
really love that um so i don't know i
guess
for today i'll call that my favorite i
don't know what sums up 2020 but
wasted on you definitely uh
was that feeling in in the get-go in the
moment of like lockdown starting and
just being like okay like
let's just belt out the reality of this
moment
um and then use my voice like
that might be the one because just over
the
over the course of time that had already
built up but especially over the course
of 2020 it just felt like there was so
much
to go okay that's it i'm putting my foot
down about um
and to stand up and
say okay everybody go vote
um that was important to me that was
important to all of us and that
definitely took courage because that's
not our
thing um and i i've been really inspired
seeing um people all over the world
actually
um use their voices and
fight for what's right even when it's
not popular
and even when that's dangerous and
difficult to do
um and i i really i mean it when i say i
have hope for the future
i really do it's not easy um
it's just not like that but uh
where we are now even just i i i really
feel like
popping the pimple of everything you
know that's wrong is good we have to
face what's broken
before we can fix it and get to the next
chapter
and i feel like 2020 was a big year for
just like
exposing a lot of things and awareness
about um social injustices and
a lot of that movement was just
beautiful and inspiring to me
um so you know i think that like
people being brave and being willing to
to go yeah no i want more i'm not i'm
not ready to accept
something that isn't acceptable and just
go to sleep you know
hope for hope somebody will fix it for
me um i don't know i i i have a lot of
hope for our youth and
and for our future yeah well i think
that the album title probably says sums
up what you just said the best the
bitter truth
yeah does it's not it's not it's not a
piece of cake the truth no it's not
it's hard work we've got to face it
we've got to face what's happening
so we can get we can be better people be
good in here good out there
yeah your sound and your energy like it
just
it just really um resonates so i've
always loved your music
thank you that's really cool to know um
from one badass to another
cheers congrats congrats on the new
album
thank you this was so nice thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more
please click on the subscribe button